[Music]
my name's Simon I'm just like you except
I have one huge ass secret nobody knows
I'm gay about being part of such a
meaningful modern coming-of-age film
it's just a beautiful fun sweet funny
movie and it happens to have at the
center of it a really gorgeous version
of a young man coming out I've been
thinking about why I haven't come out
yet maybe part of me wants to hold on to
who I've always been
when I read it it was something that I
felt was different than what I'd seen
before there was nothing heavy-handed
about it it was funny it dealt with
something that I think is important but
acceptance tolerance all those things
but if the world doesn't like you
playing that a mom who handles her child
coming out as beautifully as this
character does so it's kind of like the
the fantasy version of what you want a
mom to say these last few years it's
almost like I could feel you holding
your breath and I selfishly I wanted to
say those lines I wanted it to be me
because I do feel like this is for moms
or dads who or family or anyone who
maybe sees this coming down the pike or
wonders how they would handle it this is
a beautiful template what do you what
are you hoping that people take away
from this film I feel like that they
should walk away feeling like they wish
that they had Josh Duhamel and Jennifer
yeah we're good parents
I love you the campaign that you guys
have going on hashtag first love story
encouraging people to share their first
love story yeah I deserve a great love
story
and I want someone to share with when
you hear that first love story what
comes to mind for you guys what's your
first love stories mine was oh that game
right now really yeah see mine was
miners on the set of fluff Simon okay
didn't I laugh at it
Jen is an amazing catch yes sir yes sir
she deserves somebody far better you'd
be dating up no I wouldn't hit that was
the case yes